hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about aikido's
ground game so what is the ground game
in aikido what's going on with that and
that's what today's episode is going to
be about
all right so what is aikido's ground
grappling game
what's that all about um the the first
thing i have to say is aikido doesn't
have a ground
grappling game almost so
there are a few points in aikido that
are on the ground and things we do need
to talk about um
it's not really ground grappling and
we're going to use this video to suss
out exactly why it's not ground
grappling
and we'll kind of talk about some little
caveats that need to be added we'll talk
about some situations where aikido's
ground game
is perhaps even better than brazilian
jiu jitsu's ground game
and we'll also talk about a lot of times
when it's not better than brazilian jiu
jitsu's ground game
and how we need to kind of juggle the
difference between those two and also
how we can train those things
so that's what today's episode is going
to be about i'm going to call josh and
mai out here
we're going to go to work josh maya
okay so aikido's ground grappling game
and what is that
i would like to say first off aikido
doesn't have a ground grappling game
if you want to learn to ground grapple
you should go to a school where they
specialize in that
so go learn brazilian jiu jitsu or
western wrestling something where they
specialize in ground grappling
now there's two reasons for that one
reason is simply they'll have better
techniques better strategies better
tactics than aikido will have
foreground grappling because they spend
all their time doing that second reason
is
they will have better staff and better
people to practice with so meaning you
know even if your aikido school wants to
really figure out all the best
techniques and tactics and strategies
for ground grappling
you guys won't do it as well as someone
where they've been doing that
for decades right so go to a school
where
the people were raised in a lineage of
ground grappling and they've done it all
the time and everyone else there is
there to practice ground grappling and
they do it dedicated as a dedicated
practice
they're going to be better at ground
grappling and so that's where you should
learn ground grappling now that doesn't
mean that you
have to just study ground grappling you
can then go study other martial arts too
right so
the world's a big place where we can set
anything we want so you don't have to be
locked into a martial art and say
oh this martial art has to teach me
everything about life or i will upset my
sensei and have to commit seppuku or
[Music]
so it's it's a free world go go study
what you want if you want to get good at
ground grappling go to a school where
they study that
okay now when i say that aikido doesn't
have a ground grappling game
people inside the iq community are very
likely to say ah
but we do haven't you seen the
ancient pictures of yuashiba doing
ground grappling
[Music]
we've seen those pictures and just
because yuishiba did some ground
grappling at one point in time doesn't
mean that aikido
has ground grappling in it what the
founder did and the system that was
created and the system that's been
around
a long time since the founder's been
dead is a different thing than
than him himself and what he ever did
possibly in the world
okay aikido's ground game is very very
limited to
one thing which is pinning on the ground
and the way in which we pin on the
ground in aikido is very different than
you would see in brazilian jiu jitsu
and for a good reason now if you want to
just talk about this part of aikido's
ground game
it might actually be better than
brazilian jiu jitsu
okay so let me get josh and my here uh
josh go ahead and put maya into an ekyo
pin
facing the camera
all right so this is a standard ekyo pin
um this pin if you did brazilian jitsu
would probably look like a weird
intermediary position
and you'd be like oh this is not
actually a very good pin from a
brazilian jiu jitsu standpoint
if you're an aikido person you might
look at this and go what's wrong with
this why would brazilian jiu-jitsu
people not like this pin
what's going on with that okay now first
of all without
changing anything on josh's end we
should ask
how much freedom does maya have so if
maya just moves around how much freedom
does she have
okay she's got all that kind of freedom
all right she's got that could she roll
over maybe could she get over
okay pretty easy for her to roll over
all right good all right now so if you
study brazilian jiu jitsu you look at
that and you say
man that's a sucky pin she has so much
freedom right so i understand that
brazilian jiu jitsu when you're trying
to
pin someone to the ground you need to
eliminate as much wiggle room as they
have right so the more they can get
their legs and their other arm involved
to get you the harder it's going to be
for you to pin them you want to pin them
in a way that
locks their core down really well so
they can't resist you and this josh is
only holding
her arm right so this doesn't look very
good okay now let's see a top
mount
all right now in brazilian jiu jitsu
this is top mount it's one of the
dominating positions
when i was doing tournaments it was
worth four points i don't know if it's
still worth four points but
so this is this is top position okay now
this top position
is a good position to have because the
weight the major part of josh's weight
is sitting
on maya's core right maya's legs are
locked out behind josh it's really hard
for maya to get her legs involved in
josh right so
she could push against the ground she
might be able to nudge him forward with
her legs but
really she's probably not gonna like in
a movie whip her legs around his head
and pull him down or something that's
probably not gonna happen
so this is a really good pin the only
thing josh kind of has to deal with is
her arms a little bit
arm's relatively weak in this situation
so pretty pretty good pin for josh okay
so um if maya were to move from this
position just move around a little bit
okay josh can kind of stay with her and
she's not trying too hard and he's not
trying too hard right now because
they do this and in fact we're going to
see this in just a second okay so what
we're going to do next you guys can go
ahead and stand up
all right so what we're going to do next
is we're going to
run a simulation with these guys and we
put maya in the echo pin and we're going
to run it for
for 30 seconds and we're going to see
how many times maya can escape josh's
pin
from an equal position then we're going
to have josh getting top mount
we're going to have maya try and escape
top mount for 30 seconds and we're going
to see how how many times she can get
that
now understand these two are about the
same size right so
not a big difference in size here josh
has been doing it a little longer than
maya but
my's been doing time too right so it's
not like she's way out class or
something
technically so this is going to be a
pretty fair matchup between these two
now when you watch this you might say
oh but an expert and an expert and it's
like we're not talking about the elite
level guys we're just talking about
regular people who have some training in
ground grappling and regular people have
some training in aikido and what would
that look like so let's check this
scenario out
[Music]
okay all right so that is a comparison
of those two
same people doing uh an ekyo style pin
and a brazilian jitsu style pin which is
the top mount
and how easy they are to escape from i.e
how secure they are so
security versus autonomy is going to be
one of the big things we talk about in
aikido versus brazilian jiu jitsu stuff
so when we're talking about aikido's
ground game how did aikido's pin
looked compared to brazilian jiu jitsu's
and everybody can draw their own
conclusion
for me personally the eco looks like
it's not even
a quarter as secure as the top mount
does the top mount looks good
so that's how that looks let's look at
this situation exact same drill
except both of these guys are going or
one of these guys is going to be armed
so the person who's
in the pinned position will be armed and
we'll see how that plays out from both
the eco
and from the top mount
[Music]
good job
um
[Music]
okay so that's how both the top mount
and the eco pin look when someone's
armed
now we can start to kind of think about
how different that looks right so
notice that when maya had the
knife in the top mount she was able to
usually get a couple good quick stabs in
right away so if that position was
obtained without having control the
knife so meaning the knife came out or
the person doing brazilian jitsu didn't
know that the knife was out
then she's probably going to get that
one stab you saw that pretty
consistently even when josh knew that
there was a knife coming at him
it's pretty hard to stop that really
exciting fast action there
okay then we also saw what happened when
josh is controlling the arm
with the knife right so now this is a
little bit of an unfair comparison and
the problem i have
in combining these drills for you guys
right now is that they're two different
systems and they look at things
differently so
in order to have that pin we would have
to already have known there was a knife
in play
or at least assumed there was a knife in
place so let's say we assumed that there
was a knife in play
and so by assuming that there's a knife
in play with that we've we've come down
and controlled that arm and so if there
was a knife
if it came from the other side you'd be
well ahead of it if it came from this
side
either it wouldn't or you would already
have it under control so it's a little
bit of an
unfair comparison to compare those two
that way all right but let's see
how that looks with autonomy so
autonomy and why might autonomy be
important in those two drills so
again we're going to run the eco pin
versus the
top mount pin with autonomy being the
issue and autonomy just means freedom
and aikido doesn't put a premium on
on security but does put a premium on
autonomy so let's see how that looks
when we play that
[Music]
out
okay so now we've seen a situation with
the top mount versus the eco in an
unarmed situation
top mount versus eco in an armed
situation and now we've seen
top mount versus ikkyo in an a situation
where you need to get out of the pin
right so actually escape the pin
now why might that be important well if
the guy's got a buddy and you're holding
him down and his buddy comes in
you're way more likely i mean you can
draw your own conclusions but from my
opinion
you're way more likely to get out of
there safely from an eco-style pen
than you are to get out from a top mount
pin right so
top mount is more secure no doubt about
it in my mind you guys can draw your own
conclusions we
you saw the drill but in my opinion top
mount is way more secure if i just
absolutely want to hold person down
right so
say i know i'm in numbers right most
people in this place are on my side
then top mount is probably going to be a
good way to go as long as i'm stronger
or more skilled or whatever than the guy
i'm dealing with
but if i'm in a situation that's unknown
right so he's got more friends than i
got
the last thing i want to try and do is
that top mount because it's very likely
his friends are going to
intervene there and i'm going to be in a
bad way and i can't escape the pin
whereas with the eco you can't escape
and i think that's pretty clear from
what we saw draw your own conclusions
but
and to be fair uh about the top mount
pin
my knees a little messed up right now so
i'm not quite as fast as i should be
to get on josh but you can see that i
was trying my best to get him and
and maya was trying her best to get in
there okay now let's look at
one more situation we're going to look
at a couple variations
for the armed grappling with josh having
the weapon and one of those variations
is going to be josh
having the weapon uh in his belt but
doesn't have it drawn so he's choosing
the eco pin
but he's got a weapon in his belt that
he could get to right so this is
a typical law enforcement kind of
situation and more important than that
for the context of aikido
typical classical old battlefield
situation where i would have a weapon in
my belt
and i'm holding some guy down and they
start to give me trouble with that so
we're going to look at a situation like
that
we're also going to look at the
situation if josh already has a weapon
in his hand
and maya's holding his wrist so she's
going to be holding his wrist which
would essentially be a
yakute dory if they stood up but she'll
be holding his wrist in that echo pin
and the reason that we might go to that
echo pin is because she's holding my
wrist i'm trying to force her down force
her down force her down so what does
that look like so let's look at these
two aikido situations both 30 second
drills and see how it looks when
the person holding the pin has a weapon
themselves
[Music]
yep
time
[Music]
all right guys so that is a pretty
complete package as far as i can tell
to show you guys the difference between
these two pins aikido's
only ground game built into the system
is pinning someone on the ground
that's its ground game that's not much
of a ground game
right so meaning don't think in any way
as an aikido practitioner you
have good ground grappling skills okay
now
should you get good ground grappling
skills as an aikido student
someone just learning aikido i
personally think it's unimportant i'll
get to why i think it's unimportant in a
second
however as a complete martial artist
absolutely you should be studying ground
grappling just like you should be
studying
striking art and learning to shoot a gun
and if you want to become a complete
martial artist that's your goal is to
become a complete person who can take
care of themselves and and defend
themselves and their family
then of course you absolutely have to
study ground grappling i've done it i
think it's good i recommend my students
do it
i have another class here at the school
where we go over ground grappling
but ground grappling is its own thing
and you have to understand the strengths
and limitations of ground grappling and
when it's good and when it's bad
in the system of aikido you can see
because we put a premium on weapons and
we put a premium on autonomy the ability
to deal with multiple people to get out
of a situation really quick
our ground game is limited to pins that
allow us to a
quickly get out of them and b control
someone with a weapon
or also allow me to get to my weapon
while controlling them and you could see
when josh had the weapon either it was
in his belt or it was in his hand
it was effortless for him to um escape
that
and while there's this famous picture of
yuishiba doing ground grappling
that picture is not nearly as
important as the many many pictures the
maybe dozens of pictures we have of him
holding someone down and then holding
his hand over their head like this which
is a tag atana which just means a hand
knife which is representative of some
weapon that is holding over someone's
head
and you can see when we put josh in that
position the pin
of ikkyo was amazingly successful right
so
meaning that as long as he had that um
that ability to to hold the arm for a
second while he'd get the knife free
maya never got very far before she got
started getting loaded up with stabs and
that doesn't mean the fight wouldn't
continue but it gives josh a really
strong position to go from
now there are lots of problems when
you're looking at this and and there's
lots of things you can you can pick on
because
they're two different systems so i'm
doing the best i can to kind of compare
strategical ideas from both systems but
the important thing is not that you just
look at this and and say that oh we have
the ultimate answers or we don't have
the ultimate answers
you guys need to do these drills for
yourself so if you're interested in how
aikido really works right
you need to run these kinds of drills
run drills where
one or both people are armed and you try
classic
um ground grappling stuff and you try
aikido stuff right do pins where
you have someone else try to come in
while you're pinning and see if you can
pin
and escape the other person right try
that from both so do the drills for
yourself
right so we can have internet arguments
all day but you guys need to be doing
these
in your schools that's how you're going
to learn from this stuff so
these are a good fundamental set of
drills we ran them for 30 seconds for
the most part that's that's
enough right so a 30 second drill of
just trying to escape top mount
it can be a lot especially if you
haven't done that before be a whole lot
um so
so you know pick how much time is
appropriate use safe training weapons
for this
don't use live weapons please um
certainly
try to stay with softer weapons for this
kind of drill where there's a lot of
stabbing going on
so train it for yourself that's what's
important i'm christopher hine thanks a
lot for watching